julia roberts escapes a close brush with
death that happened while she was
shooting her new series homecoming and
it's all thanks to her co-star Shea
Whigham I got the details at last
night's big premiere Shea came down the
red carpet and he told me that he
potentially saved your life he totally
saved my life no no I don't know I saved
her life on the second scene that I
worked with her only the humongous
windscreen was up with metal and I see
it falling and I went to go cover he
lunged at me I didn't I've known him for
two days at that point I was a little
taken aback and put himself on top of me
so the heavy thing did not kill me so he
did save my life
and last night Julius fashion was giving
me life the pretty woman was pretty in
hot pink Brandon Maxwell at the
homecoming premiere your seatbelt in the
10 episode Amazon Prime series Dermot
Mulroney plays Julia's boyfriend the on
screen reunion comes 21 years after my
best friend's wedding for my best friend
has won best in my best friend's wedding
you don't end up together in homecoming
we don't know yet what happens you do
see us fleetingly in a relationship so
it doesn't really look like it's a magic
happening now regardless of how their
relationship plays out Julia already has
her sights set on season two we're all
in it we are we've got our creative
juices flowing for season two and I just
have to say I've watched the first few
episodes of this show get ready to binge
your heart out
clear a whole Saturday it is so good
[Music]